Michael Bay's first Transformers movie
turned Megan Fox into an instant star
men's magazines couldn't get enough of
her and her future and Hollywood seems
all but bulletproof who knew that a mere
decade later Fox would still be playing
second fiddle to CGI creation outside of
the running on fumes Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles franchise her box office
prospects have been pretty dire of late
I am still socially relevant here's why
Hollywood won't cast megan fox anymore
transformer trouble you'd think an
actress would stay faithful to the
franchise that launched her stardom but
there's been some bad blood between
megan fox and the crew of transformers
when Michael Bay cast Megan Fox in 2007
toy centric blockbuster she was still
mostly unknown outside of a few small TV
roles by the time Transformers Revenge
of the Fallen rolled out in 2009 Fox was
a megastar who had a few mega problems
with her starring vehicle Fox took shots
at the effects-heavy revenge telling
Entertainment Weekly quote people are
well aware that this is not a movie
about acting and quotes but even that
comment was tame compared to the way she
described Michael Bay he wants to be
like Hitler on his set and he is looks
comparing your boss to history's most
infamous Jenna Seidel dictator isn't
going to fly in most workplaces they
told GQ that while Fox was part of the
rehearsal process for Transformers Dark
of the Moon early on she was dropped
before filming begins they recalled
quote Fox was in a different world on
her blackberry you got to stay focused
and you know the Hitler thing Steven
Spielberg said fire her right now end
quote
dark of the Moon screenwriter Aaron
Kruger echoed that sentiment saying that
Fox seems like an actress who didn't
want to be a part of it she was saying
she wanted to but she wasn't acting like
it slap fest transformers may have raked
in truckloads of cash but Megan Fox's
three follow-up film crashed and burned
spectacularly first was 2009's
Jennifer's body a low-budget horror
thriller that attempted to build off
Fox's growing star power by putting her
front and center in the marketing
campaign but reviews were mixed and the
r-rated film earns a mere 6.8 million
dollars on his opening weekend
then Fox appeared in 2010 Jonah Hex a
critical and box office disaster she now
openly admits that Jonah Hex was a
turkey saying in 2016 that no one should
ever see that movie the same year Fox
made a stab for indie cred with passion
play a 2010 drama starring Mickey Rourke
Bill Murray and Rhys Ifans
despite the all-star cast the film was
critically reviled and only played in a
handful of theaters before being dumped
to DVD even Mickey Rourke slammed it
dubbing it another terrible movie on his
resume and Mickey Rourke knows a few
things about terrible movies overexposed
around the time of the one - career
sucker punch of revenge of the Fallen
and Jennifer's Body
the Megan Fox backlash began the
combination of the math of marketing for
her movies and her appearance on every
late-night talk show magazine and online
photo gallery caused serious Fox fatigue
Megan Fox media focus aspiration
syndrome is a neurobiological disorder
stemming from an oversaturation of Megan
Fox related media it got so bad several
men's websites actually called for a day
without Megan Fox boycott when even
askmen.com is tired of seeing Fox in
various states of undress something is
definitely off this beautiful morning
you landed on it definitely false starts
Fox has been linked to a number of
would-be franchises over the years
including a film version of the 90s bad
girl comics Adam which revolves around
aquatic heroine Aspen but the project
stalled with Fox admitting in 2014 that
she may be getting too old to play the
20-something character and with so much
of the film set underwater unless James
Cameron is going to direct it I don't
know how we're going to make it happen
and seriously if you're looking to get
tasked your sex icon typecasting this
probably isn't the role to make it
happen Jane Eyre maybe or Lady Wolfman
but not aspen fox did return to
blockbuster filmmaking as april O'Neil
in the 2014 Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
reboot but after the sequel Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles out of the shadows
growth half of what its predecessor made
the
installment may never make it out of
it's shell marching yet another failed
franchise in the Fox filmography a
comedic return Fox has found success in
recent years by taking supporting roles
in comedies where she can tweak her
aloof glamorous image she showed off her
comedic side which turns in this is 40
and the dictator and joined new girl as
a regular cast member in 2016 while
stars owee Deschanel was on maternity
leave
meanwhile her role in the James Franco
period comedy zero Vil proved that
there's life after Bay for Megan Fox if
she keeps working in roles like these
Megan Fox may still have a long career
in Hollywood ahead of her and hey if
acting jobs dry out Fox can always try
working as a studio executive I am going
to eat your soul see she's a natural
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to